what is up Gamers welcome back to
another Mr Beast gaming video I have a
hundred noobs trapped in this box and we
have a very special guest scappy I'm
ready to explode things he's gonna help
me torture these guys blah blah let's
get started I've watched a few of your
videos and I noticed you're way too nice
to these people so I'm gonna flip this
switch and I want you to instantly kill
five of them got you all right it has
begun last man standing wins ten
thousand dollars oh God people fell to
their death Paws if you don't know who
this guy is this is his channel he's a
big YouTuber he pulls lots of views and
he's teaming with Carl oh this poor guy
yep kill him skip all right that's one
two
three I'm turning to skip into a minute
kill some um oh skip he's there with
lava should we I don't know okay oh that
way there just go go go the other way go
get another way get away from exact
opposite direction and just so you
viewers know this is a ginormous map
with thousands of hiding spots and the
last person alive gets ten thousand
dollars no joke this guy has shot Mr
Beast merch on he thinks because he's
wearing shot Mr Beast merch No One's
Gonna Hurt Him and that's correct I'm
gonna leave him alone hey hey buddy
Chris hey Jimmy you should come check
this out all they have to do is stand
here for 10 grand uh that is not factual
guppy is lying oh all right oh you just
killed like three people whoa skip was
that you the center is lava it just
happened oh my God how did you do that
what oh my gosh look at that box in the
middle yeah there's a lava there is it
gonna extend I wonder if it'll extend
wait teach me how to do that tell me all
right come over here come over here left
click this right here okay here left
click and then right click right click
oh oh I did it let's do some dirt
whatever Skippy just did lag the entire
map oh all right oh you're gonna have
some Angry Kids on our heads no I I have
to go now I'll see you guys later oh the
server just crashed did it it's crashed
the service crashed
unreal it was an honest accident we
don't hate them everyone's back in here
we're gonna keep going we turned on PVP
let's see if they start fighting bro who
gave this man ender pearl shot Mr Beast
yeah shot Mr Beast has anything he
desires oh well okay now he has a bucket
of lava what you're giving him a bucket
a lot I'm gonna give him a diamond
you go near shot Mr space for five
seconds and he's dead oh come on come on
now that wasn't my fault scampi doesn't
want us to sell merch confirmed oh
there's somebody coming up there's
somebody coming up
Battle Stations should we get him let's
get him let's get him let's get him oh
we got him we got him we got him
we're gonna hook him up with the diamond
sword boom boom boom boom oh he's going
for it he's ready he's on the prowl oh
they're swarming to him keep him marked
they're swarming to him let's see oh Ash
wants it Ash Ketchum oh oh my gosh they
have a full team here oh they're teaming
up their stream this YouTuber right here
that's literally him oh my gosh Carl
Jedi I think there's an alliance going
on here oh whoa whoa whoa whoa oh Mr
Beast is here Mr Beast is here hey he's
holding something Chris is here too get
ready to dip get ready to leave they're
catching on get out get out get out get
out get out get out get out get out get
out get out no Carl Carl hi Joe head
over here Hide closer to the edge okay
they won't see us here they're right
here they're right here
they don't see us they don't see us this
is terrifying they disbanded their their
plans oh this guy's got diamond stuff
Chris what was that I've been training
this guy I found him and I got him out
of a corner and he's gonna become the
guy who kills for Ray watch him go kill
for Ray come on he looks ferocious all
right he's like are you not entertained
why are you not entertained all right
you know what we need to do I feel like
we need to start lobbying off parts of
the map oh I'm a pro at that one yeah I
wonder how everyone over here is like
keeping six inches apart I'm not just AC
130. no Chris that's gonna make them go
back inside you number sorry I can't
hear you all the Snowballs what all
right your mom
to me I really want to snowball up but
he's shaking his head no at me
[Laughter]
first yeah just get ready he's about to
spawn get away get away get away from me
wait somebody look somebody has the
helmet curse of binding on I just
trapped Carl in this room he can't get
out he has no way except for to die oh
get out get out get out get out what are
we gonna do get down get down eat your
steak eat your steak if you need to make
a jump if you need to he's on the higher
floor Chris is trying to kill me you can
oh God okay I'm going down I'm jumping
here oh no I didn't know
you guys are so mean to me Chris killed
you I did I I didn't know how low were
you Chris how come it's always I didn't
know I didn't know how low was your
health the snowball does one damage you
just threw a snowball on me
all right so I just left the club for a
few minutes what is going on I literally
have no idea okay so I'm around the map
right now this dude is op This Guy's in
a tree a literal tree and he's wearing a
pumpkin Jimmy sucks hehe so is Steppy
all right uh let's just write skeppy
good dream can uh you know just be
careful of the lava look they're so
scared of me I have so much power what
do you have nothing one for me Skippy's
here he's here just look out
I don't know what he's gonna do please
give me leave me leave me alone skeppy
47 people remain hey let's is he a
regular on your server uh I don't
recognize
death death
not destruction death and destruction oh
they're gone they're I'm helping dude I
like this being destructive is more fun
oh yeah it is it is way more fun to just
destroy everything yeah exactly this
guy's got two swords what the heck he's
got two swords dude is frayed creative
why can't no one hurt him I feel like
he's he's like wait that might he goes
if I'm doing something wrong he's like
I'm sorry I guess I thought I was here
to destroy oh he said no can't be you
scared him
I didn't do anything hey hooray come
over here actually free you are in
between me and skeppy pick who your
favorite is oh I have a potato I will
give you pick your favorite oh my gosh
just because he's giving away the money
for Ray listen listen take it it's all
you're right all I'm saying is all I'm
saying is I'm giving away 10 grand today
for a pick who do you like better would
you rather say 10K or potato right you
have five seconds make your decision or
I'll Slaughter you pick don't make me
look stupid
he wants the money all right all right
yo get him out out hey no no no no hey
back up backwards
I will defend you with my life no one
touches for it Dad come over here
[Applause]
oh I like that before I get out of there
get out of there run run someone bad
skip hey
you could have had all these potatoes
hey hey take away the privilege love a
takeaway
I'm doing the water I'm doing the water
hooray I'm fighting so hard for you
right now he ran out they're going after
him I can't get out these windows I'm
gonna I'm gonna heal him I'm gonna heal
him you are not killing him skip I'm
sorry I said we just sit here yeah I say
we like try and stay in this corner
because they're not they're more likely
not going to see us over here and we
also have the best escape here like I
think going down here is the best way
out skip I'd like to have a
heart-to-heart talk with you all right
I'm down to listen right here right here
all right man to man
foray is off limits I mean but yeah I
I'm gonna need you to leave my boy all
right well I'm also off limits I don't
know if that was made clear game mode
three hey no oh my god the guy in spawn
keeps killing me what is this devolving
into why are there ocelots all over the
center of the match yeah I looked at a
guy and he just turned around and it was
like he thought if you turned around I
wouldn't see him what are you looking at
better walk away he was so excited and
then he just sort of slowly created am I
gonna die oh
where'd that come from wait who spun
lava up top oh did I cut it in force
hold on we can just make a path do you
want to be skappy Chris kinda he's
pretty good at Minecraft this has been
going on for quite a while if you look
at the map it's in Ruins but somehow
there's still over 30 people alive I
think we need to you know focus on them
yeah I get you they all have to kill at
least one person in the next two minutes
or we'll kick them but here's the thing
skip I have no way of tracking that I'm
just gonna see if they believe me
okay let them know all right this is
gonna be a bloodbath okay wait is Carl's
team gonna turn on each other you have
two minutes to kill someone or you'll be
kicked
oh God okay let's go across the building
let's go across the building this guy
here let us let us kill him let us kill
him how about this I'll boost you two up
and then I'll try and jump across here
and I'll give you my armor first in case
I die so all three of you guys got the
kills right yeah we threw we got kills
yeah take those guys okay I'm gonna
boost you up okay so now that you guys
have all gotten the kills it's clear to
tell you guys that uh Jimmy was fibbing
he there's no way to tell if you guys
all got kills bro
Ray's about to die where is he is about
to die come on finally the moment I was
waiting okay yes yes this is it Alan
gaming is my Champion oh he he's going
after him he's got foray on the ropes
wait really oh foray no parade does have
diamond armor though and Allen only has
leather great face of my command oh he
lost his chest plate hooray Frey dog no
no foreign
[Music]
go off these people down here are
fighting oh I'm oh they're all ganging
up on this one guy he's low he's low
he's really low he's really low get up
get up get up Miss Reese is doing
something I don't know what he's doing
but he's doing something oh God we can't
get up should we kill this guy should we
kill this guy oh they tried blocking Us
in they tried blocking Us in be careful
here's the thing guys you're all too
good and there's only four other people
left you guys are no longer allowed to
work together because stream is so
freakishly good we took away his armor
we permanently stuck a pumpkin to his
head I don't think you realize I
literally can't see
my whole screen is like a pumpkin face
seven people remain only one is getting
10 grand PVP is back on I'm unreleasing
them let's see what happens who's that
oh oh dream has already killed somebody
which and I died wait Jedi is dead oh
somebody fished me in the lava no no no
no no
big c big c big c oh no don't die Big C
no that's it pop three jerk two oh wait
if jerkshire wins he gets 10 grand again
he's but a 14 year old boy go jerksu yo
Jeff no one was even helping sharks do
this video also we actually permanently
stuck a pumpkin on his own oh oh
this is oh
thank you for coming out congrats on
your 10 grand anything you want to say
to the world
uh
uh noted noted congrats on your 10 grand
thanks for coming out skip thank you
dream for coming out sorry you didn't
win maybe you actually aren't better
than technoblade that's a joke we'll see
you in the next video